[Música]
muy bienvenidos una nueva emisión de la
entrevista de Franz 24 en español nos
acompaña en esta oportunidad remix
director general de la agencia francesa
de desarrollo señor muchas gracias por
su presencia en France 24
excelente
realizan trabajos en América Latina en
relación al cuidado del medio ambiente
el desarrollo sostenible y de energías
renovables de hecho usted está en México
con varios proyectos Cuáles considera
que son las principales amenazas para
los recursos naturales de la región
la afd probablemente sea más conocida
por áfrica o por los territorios
franceses de ultramar pero latinoamérica
es una prioridad principal para nosotros
se han invertido alrededor de 15 mil
millones de euros en los últimos 10 años
y realmente promovemos la protección de
la biodiversidad y la lucha contra el
cambio climático creo que estos dos
desafíos están profundamente
interrelacionados
financing aquí en México estuve en
Chiapas visitando las represas
hidroeléctricas que estamos financiando
y también visitaré los proyectos de
permacultura en la región de México son
pequeños y grandes proyectos para que
las autoridades tengan la certeza de que
es posible hacer la transición hacia una
economía y unas sociedades más
sostenibles
the mencionaba recién a las autoridades
qué cree que necesitamos de ella para
cuidar y encarar todos estos temas
bueno
bueno todos los gobiernos acordaron en
2015 una serie de objetivos comunes
llamados los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible yo fui el jefe negociador en
materia de finanzas en París durante el
acuerdo de París sobre el cambio
climático la agenda está Clara lo
importante ahora es implementarla Es
decir definir trayectorias ambiciosas
para 2030 y 2050
estoy aquí para hablar esta semana con
las autoridades de México y Brasil sobre
sus aspiraciones y también estoy aquí
para movilizar y hablar con bancos
públicos de desarrollo aliados al 85 en
Latinoamérica para que estas
instituciones convenzan a sus gobiernos
de que es factible financiar e
implementar esta transición
Están pasando muchas cosas en
Latinoamérica en este sentido Pero
tenemos que hacer más tenemos que
apresurarnos y la cooperación
internacional es clave para eso
International cooperation is
what estamos hablando ahora en medio de
un contexto geopolítico muy particular
con la guerra de en Ucrania que está
teniendo efectos devastadores en la
seguridad alimentaria y también en el
abastecimiento de alimentos básicos como
cereales y otros productos
agroalimenticios América Latina podría
ser una alternativa para los mercados
globales y cómo se ve afectada la región
es verdad estamos viviendo una sucesión
de análisis después del covid ahora la
guerra en Ucrania está desestabilizando
las cadenas de valor globales y
amenazando la seguridad alimentaria en
muchas regiones del mundo
latinoamérica with atención
y debemos prestarle atención a
latinoamérica porque probablemente fue
la región más afectada por el
cómics
clases hay que recordar las recesión de
2020 y la recuperación Todavía es muy
lenta las clases medias los países de
ingresos medios fueron los más duramente
afectados por la pandemia En comparación
con otras regiones o con otros países
ahora tenemos que repensar las cadenas
de valor probablemente sea una evolución
positiva para la integración regional
Espero que al igual que en Europa y en
África surja de la crisis del mercado
común entre los países latinoamericanos
y las cadenas de valor que están más
cerca más localizadas y como equipo
europeo estamos listos tanto la fd como
otras organizaciones para invertir en la
experiencia latinoamericana
American experience
acaba de mencionar África usted tiene
mucha experiencia trabajando en el
Continente desde que inició su primer
mandato en Manuel macron ha planteado
que los vínculos entre Francia y el
continente africano son ahora entre
pares de igual a igual cómo se tradujo
esto en el modelo de trabajo de la afd
en África hubo un cambio con macron en
el poder
Bueno de hecho la f de nació en África
en 1941 No nació en tiempos coloniales
se llamó el banco de liberación fue
fundado por el general de Gol en Londres
y Poco después en África Central Así que
conocemos a África desde hace mucho
tiempo y valoramos lo que ha pasado en
África Durante los últimos 30 años es un
inmenso Progreso que las personas tienen
que reconocer y entender
la redefinición que el presidente marcon
ha puesto en marcha entre Francia Europa
y África es totalmente consistente en lo
que la AF de está haciendo por ejemplo
nuestras operaciones en la afd siempre
cuenta con los actores locales nuestra
financiación pasada a través de
entidades locales contrapartes locales
Así que conocemos muy bien conocemos
desde adentro del valor de algunas
instituciones africanas
window from the inside the value
Esperamos que la percepción sobre África
cambie con el tiempo y que haya más
inversiones positivas masivas en
oportunidades para la juventud
y además estamos subestimando el tamaño
de África en 2050 uno de cada tres
jóvenes vivirá en África un artista o un
deportista ser africano tenemos que
empezar a entender eso Y por supuesto la
fd También está lista para ayudar en
materia de finanzas en la cooperación
trilateral en una cooperación sur sur
entre latinoamérica y África las
regiones con una historia muy larga muy
dramática en ciertos aspectos pero
también muy positiva eso probablemente
pueda ayudar a que la agenda de
desarrollo sostenible se cumpla
pero regiones
usted acaba de mencionar algunos temas
de África pero le quiero preguntar esta
región tiene por supuesto sus problemas
y necesidades particulares Cuáles son
los más urgentes
las necesidades en África tienen que ver
con la seguridad alimentaria es decir
con la comida las regiones más afectadas
por la Guerra de Ucrania son las
fronteras mediterráneas en especial las
que dependen del trigo ucraniano y Ruso
Así que hay un esfuerzo humanitario
urgente por lidiar con la seguridad
alimentaria
pero la seguridad alimentaria será
sostenible a largo plazo solo si se
invierte en la agricultura y si los
países africanos se vuelven más
autodependientes de sus propios recursos
en este sentido tal vez haya algo que
aprender de la experiencia
latinoamericana en materia agrícola
México es un productor importante y
exportador de productos agrícolas Brasil
también
por supuesto No se trata de hacerlo
exactamente de la misma manera porque
debemos lograr que las producciones sean
sostenibles pero sin duda Hay mucho que
compartir
usted tiene experiencia en muchísimas
áreas fue también director de Franz
media montt Franz 24 en español ha sido
un puente clave a nivel mediático y
también cultural entre Francia y América
Latina cuál cree usted que es el
principal aporte del Canal a la región y
también a los vínculos entre Francia y
Latinoamérica
[Música]
es verdad también estoy en la región
para pensar sobre eso llegaré pronto a
Madrid para hablar con nuestros colegas
que están redefiniendo la estrategia
para latinoamérica los colegas de la icd
What
hace unas semanas también estuvimos en
un foro en la sede de la ocre tenemos
que pensar que estamos haciendo juntos
entre Europa en especial Francia y
latinoamérica y pienso que hay que
recordar la agenda de desarrollo
sostenible los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible y las propuestas que
latinoamérica le hizo el resto del mundo
inicialmente Europa se resistió a una
agenda tan ambiciosa pensando que tal
vez no era factible pero ahora es una
política común las dos regiones Europa
de cerdo verde y latinoamérica con esa
insistencia en la transición en Cómo
reconciliar la igualdad y el medio
ambiente son las más avanzadas en esas
trayectorias tenemos que desembocar en
un mundo donde haya buena salud buena
educación suficiente ingreso per cápita
pero con una economía circular en la que
no se destruye el planeta
Me parece que Europa y latinoamérica son
las dos regiones más consistentes de sus
desafíos y las que están definiendo de
manera distinta claro una ruta hacia un
mundo más sostenible no solo para ellos
mismos sino para discutirla de manera
global con el resto del mundo
restaurante
gracias gracias
a usted de nuevo y a nuestra audiencia
como siempre le invitamos a que sigan
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y también por supuesto en
France 24.com siguen junto a nosotros
[Música]